hey ihr
wartet wahrscheinlich alle dass
minecraft video was heute um 18 uhr
online gehen sollte auf meinem kanal die
sache ist allerdings dass ich euch ja
bereits meiner instagram story gesagt
habe dass das video ein bisschen später
kommt jedoch kommt sie uns heute leider
gar nicht mehr das liegt einfach daran
weil und das kann ich euch ja ganz
kurzzeitig war hier vorne gerade am
aufnehmen bin und dass hier habe ich
auch schon geschafft heute zu bauen ich
möchte nämlich nur ein kleine hobbit
fröhliche bauern ich habe mir hier schon
alle sachen zusammengesucht und ihr seht
auch unten in einem inventar dass ich
auf jeden fall ein paar mehr level habe
und generell alles eigentlich super
gelaufen ist keine folge ich bin in der
aufnahme gerade bei einer stunde zehn
einer stunde 14 ca und ich nehme auch
hier vorne natürlich mit meiner kämpfst
du das passt alles hier bin ich
hannovers mal tutorial auf der seite wo
ich mich daran verhandelt die sache ist
allerdings dass sich bei ubs einfach
nicht auf aufnahme starten gedrückt habe
ich hatte mein leben da denn heute es
tut mir unfassbar leid ich habe ein
backup gemacht von der welt bevor ich
das video aufgenommen habe das mache ich
immer irgendwas schief geht die sache
ist dass heute dementsprechend keinen
minecraft wieder mal kommen weil wenn
ich es jetzt lösen würde das backup
hochladen würde hier in meinem eintrag
fällt das ganze mal aufnehmen würde dann
wäre ich frühestens um halb neun fertig
mit der aufnahme und das wird dann erst
um zehn oder elf online games schon den
ganzen tag am pc nichts von trainiert
heute ich bin einfach nur noch tot es
sind 50 grad hier in meinem aufnahme
zimmer weil sie in form dieses hätten
lichter immer habe deswegen hoffe ich
verzeihe mir dass das video ist
übermorgen kommen morgen kommt nämlich
endlich mal wieder ein video mit
paletten auf meinem kanal die spielen
battlefield zusammen und dann kommen
übermorgen diese minecraft folge es tut
mir leid ist im vordergrund meint
vielleicht ganz verstehen und alle
dieses video ist leicht allerdings
möchte ich dass das video perfekt ist
und ich will jetzt hier nicht ein auf
hey guck mal das habe ich gemacht und
ich erzähle es euch einfach weil die
aufnahme ist abgebrochen ich will das
ist ein cooles video wird weil dieser
hobbit würde die wird schon ziemlich
geil ich muss dann zwar alles noch mal
machen was ich schon gemacht habe aber
ich gern übermorgen neues video ich
hoffe ihr seid am start und wir sehen
uns dann erstmal morgen wieder um 18 uhr
oder und kanal könnt ihr auch mal
vorbeischauen ich jetzt auch wieder
aktiv geworden lupu heißt der
favorit trotzdem schönen abend